negli episodi precedenti diritto
michaels travestimento coppa da mafalda
dimmi che serviva ma fatevi ormai porca
[ __ ] vice pg madonna garanzia cos'è sto
assembramento quale era 7 era santo gesù
ma come quanto difficile via non uscire
mai più milan non ne voglio sapere dove
stai andando non uscire è stato orribile
la gente che si muove a caso va bene
allora zombie di manichini a parte
proprio non s'è staccata la porta per
ora
ma è comunque che comunque dico
normale se vogliamo proprio con le carte
ragazzi allora calmi quale va bene devi
correre di ricorrere
non sono morto
albert devi stare fermi
spiega il signor favi a raffica dei sì
ma io che devo fare mezzo sti cunicoli e
devo trovare il corso il costo per
alimentare la scienza piuttosto casinò o
una luce che le saponette saponette del
bagno perfetto in tutto ciò devo aprire
la porta con la saponetta the kid e
saponetta lancio e tutte porta s
c'è uno morto nella vasca però
lasciamoli tu devi stare fermo perché se
no veramente messi male
ragazzi ho già capito la dello sport del
nostro stare a no devo farmi seguire
e poi devo spostarla accendendo la luce
scommetti non sono sicuri come ho detto
ragazzi vediamo non è stato per niente
sicuro alla 1 vediamo se funziona devo
farvi devo metterlo lì e non era proprio
così si alzato lo zio ha sete the
picchia e stato orribile va bene grazie
alla sedia giovanni mi serve per madonna
previsto stato prima per roma donne
incontrate se madonna va tecnica ed
cacchioli di design e ciò soggiorno ma è
veramente un genio che si metta questa
roba ragazzina giuro lo stesso come
diavolo gli è venuto in mente devi stare
fermo come diavolo gli è venuto in mente
sta roba non lo so ragazzi ma si sta
facendo pesante mai allora
non penso sono troppi ragazzi non c'e la
facile tenerli
non so se si capisce quali faccio vedere
tanto conosce la dentiera posto della
faccia utile signori dove testare
indovinate come a casa a casa dove
testare e allora chiedo
qual è allora va bene va bene allora il
concerto dei one direction dai no era
lui
c'è troppa gente vabbè non ci parlo non
ci passo come facciano passati la come
mai mai mai pepe corri corri corri
su un kart ha messo sei anni ecco la
bobina l'ho trovata
c'è una sedia elettrica va bene possono
cacciare questo qua sei perfetto proprio
quello che volevo fare
questa è l'altra parte della tutto sto
bordello tutto sto bordello che si
poteva passare via tranquillamente
seconda merda potevo entrare là dentro
pre molto prima
mi tirava la tipa mi tirava su entravo
entrata parte era già arrivato mi
risparmiavo tutto sto casino
anzi aperta e pensavo di dover prender
lo sgabello
se tu mi fi cavi là dentro e poi
tiravamo il coso è arrivato al di là
senza farli tutto sto casino cioè ma ti
pare usa accusato il cervello alla
edizione ma non sono gli impermeabili
dovevo andare quando alla porta e libera
ragazzi c'abbiamo ci ho messo anni ma
sappiamo tutti e due tutte e due le
bobine come si chiamano eni l'altra va
rediti utile mafalda brava
[Musica]
ho finalmente tutto è bene quel che
finisce con i manichini zombie come
correre con la bovina spedita in
ascensore in terapia dallo psicologo
tutto quanto è comunque raga allegro è
finora il gioco questo ascensore che
scende negli inferi e mafalda immesso
che piano hai messo che in una scheda
verde
siamo all'inferno va bene qua moriamo lo
dico a questo c'è una spazzola consolata
e stanzi non ha la testa a più rumore
ricchezze che ride
ragazzi 1 che ride feriti in un
sotterraneo del genere hai dei problemi
perché non puoi non è una situazione in
cui si ride e fatelo dire
ok la falda vieni c'è un'altra boss
fight sicuro e scusate sto controllando
poi c'è una mano mi si spacca la faccia
e rimetti noury mettilo rimetti lo
rimettono forconi cannavaro ha mancato
anche la mancata
e vabbè non ci diamo più era colpita
adesso ha la bamboo l'ho ce l'ho fatta e
non è morta non è morto stacca le travi
stacca le stacca la zia e non muore
quanto tempo per st cast e travi porco
demonio ma adesso c'è tanto ormai sono
morti chi se ne frega ti do una mano io
davo d'abuso morti ci ho messo sei ore
madonna come si pensa altro ragazzi
ma.ma
ma e massimo boldi
verità appare la massa informe di
materia organica
[Musica]
passiamo da non lo guardo ma sei tu che
monti la gente a ed il caso la domanda
mia e dove cacchio devo andare sulla
gente che devo fare qua che cazzo ridi
dove chiedeva ai fatti ci si vede a
carate di progetti fratello dove devo
andare io esattamente cioè cosa devo
fare qui
qual è il mio scopo dove da dove esco a
cena
che troviamo
teoricamente teoricamente se mi metto
qui sotto magari non mi vede se posso mi
ha visto
ma visto gigi ragazzi un'auto ed non ha
visto per niente però potrebbe ancora
uscire ovviamente quindi niente
porca vacca non esisto io non esisto non
esisto devi cagarmi addosso per forza
oddio proprio su questo letto da venire
ce ne sono un milione
togliti noto andato vai vai vai vai vai
occhio che quanti l'aca qualcosa ma
dovremo andare
teoricamente soli gira dovremo andare
qua dietro
ok contro teoricamente non dovrebbe
vederci devo tirare qualcosa al bottone
cioè prendi un non so cosa cosa gli tiro
mai cascare qualcosa ti prego ci sono
gli oggetti laggiù
minchia no al casinò arrivare fin lì poi
ci provo da qui lo devo prendere uno di
quegli oggetti laggiù e tornare in via
ma da un casino ragazzi qua a moriamo
ve lo dice il signor favi vai vai vai
vai perfetto perfetto perfetto effetto
buono 6 di mafalda stai lì mafalda e con
disastro dai la togliti togliti cavo
la situazione prima fatah che cazzo fa
era di sopra era di soci pazza questa è
pazza era la se ti sei fatta per un
niente nota ha visto già incredibile di
ringraziare il cielo
poi sono entrato sono entrato sarà
entrato vice cavalcature sono
non è preso cia il labbro superiore che
un po staccato dalla faccia di te ne sei
accorto guarda vacci piano col botox del
ciao
stato mega divertente tutto questo
occhio che torna sul sicuro brava brava
falda vai vai mafalda veloce veloce ma
fa da veloce veloce veloce andale quanto
tempo va ad aprire cose
ap da fare aprire a fare aprire a fare
appena fare ap la prima prefetto ma fa
bene stato difficile ma fattibile che
cacchio è successo agli esseri umani se
posso chiedere cosa io vivo quando
finirò litl nightmares mi vorrà un lag
vi devo leggere la storia perché devo
capire cosa sta succedendo e
l'impossibile
non si capisce niente poi quegli esseri
umani sono stati baluk se ci siamo noi i
nani sono morto non so sono caduto da un
chilometro da vieni che c'è gli spigoli
la
ah no spingimi tu dici tu io vado spingi
spingi vai questa cosa potevamo farlo
anche prima con la nella parte con i
manichini potranno fare così arrivare
alla bobina subito cosa che devo
prendere qui
cosa devo fare qua dentro ragazzi che
non ho ben capito parte il fatto che può
entrare quel tizio da un secondo
all'altro qui non è proprio il massimo
stare qui però acer chiave eco maghazi
ci arriva va bene va bene ed acqua scusa
anche più o meno passato per la rincorsa
è sì ce l'ho fatta perfetto e le europee
non hanno capito che bisognava fare così
però la chiave cosa mi servi o prendi
sempre chiavi che non sa cosa servono
nessun tempo di arrivare lì che mi
arriva il coso che di sicuro adesso
arriva e io faccio in tempo a tornare
invece no tira mafalda tira ai mafalda
bravissimo
tengo la chiave è stato bravo o perfetto
ecco io ho un archivista st portino le
vedo neanche la prendo le chiavi senza
sapere dove sono le porte
meno male ragazzi mi sono cagato addosso
pensavo ci fosse una boss fight con quel
tizio invece è invece qua devo fare
parkour sui cose sicuro il salto vieni
qua mafalda seguito perfetto vieni che
ti dà una mano ce la fai da solo la
perfetta gru ragazzi possiamo uscire da
quando ero all aperto stiamo passando
posti incredibile ospedale scuola tutto
che poi non ho capito se un ospedale una
prigione secondo è una prigione non è un
ospedale ma è in tutto questo non ho ben
capito dove stiamo andando e perché non
abbiamo la vera e propria mente non
possiamo perché c'è di nuovo questo qui
basta age aerei sotto prima che palle
mi stavo virali
la bobina si sta in alto a destra non so
come ci arrivo bella
[Musica]
devo fare esattamente quello che ho
fatto prima
vero mentre certissimo credo lo so posso
salire con la gamba mi aspetto la gamba
forse forse più passante latina con la
sega fratello stai bene mentre tu giochi
coi lego io non dico a ok io vedo se
riesco a fabbriche ci fa il frontalino
ai ragazzi devo distrarlo che non ho
modo fai la bobina quella è la porta
credo si possa dire tu vai vai vai però
veloce perché sono al casinò veloci
veloci veloci vera solo brava è più
nasconditi che non so che il cambio
questo epico ancora porca vacca andiamo
di sopra intanto delle scelte né dal
lucernaio che non è una bella zucca
ok c'è uno che è ancora vivo non so se
ve ne siete accorti però io no
ho staccato la spina ho fatto un favore
il tiro adesso mi sa che devo salire
prima che con larrivey che sono più
trotta
era veramente la bobina qui come si sa
le non si sale e non lo so ha brava
brava brava brava tira tira tira tira
tira tira una mano ira madonna che
giocavo fatto e sali santo iddio e non è
un gradino kcal h
minchia regali che ha fatto un casino
sono appasionato insomma mi ha fatto di
sentirmi dai corri corri corri corri
corri corico raccolgono mamma mia
ragazzi c'è giocatori sono mafalda
subito la porta qua e che poi un casino
vai vai corribile alla porta prima
carini che sento
dove stiamo andando non lo so eccoci qua
mi ha sentito a sentire il peso morto
vai mafalda vai mafalda veloce
e calcolato sul filo del rasoio sul
posto c'e veramente basta che ha letto
millesimi di secondo
orco del demonio corri ma quando sei
calda ma dammi la mano c'è un coso
gigante sul soffitto
sarà ma io sono morto ok
e non ci sono io perdono
ma che chiede quante ne frega
prego giocatori con falsi e poi da me e
da beck e poi forse ci devo mettere a
turate
ma io posso uscire c'è un pantano qua
sotto
cacchio l'inceneritore a prima falda
barra va spinti fuori
chiudi la porta dicendo ci penso io
tira giovanna
[Musica]
chi vuole bene guarda che trova però ci
credo
mi sembra proprio di questo mettersi lì
perché poco freddo raccontiamoci delle
storie no che dici ti ricordi quando il
mondo era bello e non c'erano persone
sul soffitto ma ricordati che bei
momenti comunque era è stato è stata una
vera posta in testa ci pensava da questo
qua ma non peso nel senso che era
difficile miracolo pesante 6 1 mag
sponda adulto comunque alla torcia
accesa despota accendono anche prima
ricoverato dedicherà un ospedale la
sedia elettrica quale ospedale alla
sedia elettrica scusatevi per quello che
per quello che mi minimi e cioè ero
titubante sembra più una prigione
ragazzi bellissimo quindi abbiamo
ufficialmente finesi con la boxe fight
si è chiuso il l'ospedale la zona quindi
vamonos aprì la finestra e si va verso
la nuova zona
ho notato che quando cambi zona ci
sembra una finestra di mezzo non so
perché è così bene la città è molto
grosso adesso abbiamo provare abbiamo
fatto la scuola l'ospedale abbiamo
ancora la panetteria abbiamo ancora gli
uffici abbiamo ancora la centrale
idroelettrica abbiamo deve fare tutto
della città qualsiasi co anche casa mia
c'è tutti pieni board tutte le zone
piene di boss e per carità mincia stavo
guardando la torre sono cascato nel
vuoto o un pirla un genio immaginatevi
frodo del signore degli anelli che
arriva mordor cammina guarda sauron e
inciampa e muore genio 66 sauron quello
c'è una torre che trasmette il segnale a
tutti quanti li lobotomizza ho capito
noi dobbiamo raggiungere quella torre
guardala è sicuro il problema di tutti
quanti con la torre linee sicuro guarda
che casino
quindi c'è una torre che lancia il
segnale a tutti quanti e tutti vengono
lobotomizzati questo è il discorso c'è
un appendino sul cosa va bè bellissimo
mi aggrappo io parte non posso vieni
mafalda fammi salire che non sono saliti
aggrappati tu magari che io mi sa che
tiro il cosa no dall'altra parte azione
quindi il problema grosso è una torre
c'è una torre quello il problema
ok emo
ma come faccio mittenti mica la mano sì
che cacchio sono spider man
io ci provo lo stesso look e charlie via
ci arrivi anche senza la sua mano fai
uno di quei salti che fai di quesiti che
sono incredibili se veramente ci arrivi
anche senza prove in fondo al mar
qua ci serve mafalda che ci tiene alla
scaletta tiramisù che sei più forte di
me
riesco a madonna una torre enorme come
ci arrivo la non so se devo arrivare lì
in realtà è una supposizione la mia però
sembra essere così che va dai ragazzi
siamo inside the casa la fanta dove 66
seguendo programmi su persona fatta loro
lavoro ha fatto un casino cascate
televisioni ne pensa cascando tutto
legato mafalda mafalda sta cascando
tutto spingi la porta
abbiamo schiacciato una trave madonna e
sono veramente alto 20 centimetri ho
fatto io sto casino torri mafalda anche
col casino torri
finché ho schiacciato una trave come
possibile è la madonna è già morto ben
cascati di sotto siamo morti chi non
deve andare così dobbiamo correre a
schiaffi butta giù tutto
non comprendo come io con una trave
possa aver fatto suo casinò prova verso
la baita corri una cosa nostra da quando
è rimasta schiacciata regala
ma se io devo fare
lei è rimasta schiera rimasta
schiacciata no no no era vero io pensavo
su un bug signori concluso vi è bisogno
di oggi mamma mia che gioco pazzesco
però lo so che io interrotto sempre
quando non va bene ma fa niente perché
sennò non si casa suspense possibilità
di ragazzi sarà l'ultimo ci vediamo
appunto venerdì per il prossimo episodio
l'ultimo non mancate ragazzi di scrivete
a chiamare schiacciate il tasto mi piace
servito è piaciuta come sempre un
accigliato aru prossimo vinto
[Musica]